the world is running out of oil at least
that was the idea behind the peak oil
hypothesis that dominated economic
thinking for decades but it turns out
that with fracking deepwater drilling
and oil sands there's a lot more oil in
the world than we once thought the old
Peak Oil Theory ain't happening but what
if instead of running out of oil
we just stopped buying this stuff most
women scoff at that idea there are 1
billion gas-guzzling cars on the road
worldwide today and only 1/10 of 1% of
them have a plug
OPEC contends that even in the year 2040
EVs will make up just 1% but don't be so
sure consider the S curve s curves are
used to describe the spread of new
technologies over time like early
refrigerators and color TVs growth
starts off slowly at first and then when
the product really starts to connect
with everyday people we have liftoff
eventually the market gets saturated and
growth tapers off forming the top of yes
predicting s curves for electric cars is
extremely difficult because we're making
assumptions about demand for a type of
vehicle that doesn't even exist yet fast
affordable and spacious cars that have
an electric range of at least two 300
miles but here's what we know in the
next few years
Tesla Nissan and Chevy plan to start
selling long range electric cars in the
$30,000 range and other car makers and
tech companies are investing billions on
dozens of new models due out in the next
four years by 2020 some of these will be
faster safer cheaper and more convenient
than their gasoline counterparts that
sure seems like the point when the S
curve goes vertical
to start an oil crash you don't need to
replace all the cars on the road today
you just need to reduce demand enough to
cause a glut of unwanted oil consider
the oil crash that started in 2014 that
was caused by too much supply when
producers started pumping out an extra
two million barrels a day
so when electric vehicles are able to
displace that much on the demand side it
should also cause a crash when might
that happen Tesla is building factories
to go from about 50,000 sales last year
to 500,000 in 2020 so let's assume for a
minute that Tesla can meet its own
forecasts and let's assume that other
car makers maintain their current
combined market share for plugins if
each electric vehicle displaces roughly
15 barrels a year here's the impact on
oil from all the EVs worldwide at this
rate we hit our benchmark of 2 million
barrels of oil a day displaced as early
as 2023 that's an oil crisis and the
thing is it's just the beginning it's
not at all unreasonable to assume that
by 2040 nearly half the world's new cars
will have a plug sure you're skeptical
the price of electric cars still needs
to come down and there aren't yet enough
fast charging stations for convenient
long distance road trips many new
drivers in developing countries like
China and India they're still going to
choose gasoline diesel but imagine a
future where the rumbling streets of New
York and New Delhi suddenly fall silent
with electric engines what if global
demand for oil starts to fall at first
by trickle but then in a rush
trillions invested in oil will be lost
while trillions in new energy
the power of Nations will be shuffled
that's the promise of the new peak oil
and it may be coming sooner than you
think